[Music]
obviously a lot of people in our
audience use Craigslist we've got a lot
of young fans they use Craigslist I
thought would help our audience members
tonight make a sale or a connection by
showing some of their craigslist ads
right here on the show as a service I
think it's very nice let's check them
out right now first one missed
connection you changing into your night
down me outside in your tree
we go next one service offered retired
middle school vice-principal will come
to your house and threaten your kids
with a belt
[Applause]
[Music]
housing swap housing swap beautiful home
in Santa Monica includes outdoor deck
and alcoholic husband
[Music]
for sale for sale 97 Dodge Viper great
condition but stereo is jammed and won't
stop playing a single of who let the
dogs out
[Applause]
there we go lost sex tape I made with
prick
[Music]
even that musicians wanted to become
totally equal partners in my band
Armando Goldfarb presents the Armando
Goldfarb experience featuring Armando go
far here we go a man seeking woman come
rule the post-apocalyptic wasteland with
me after the coming machine uprising
[Applause]
and finally wanted looking for a dope
young lady named Mary Jane to party with
me at 4:20 contact me at not a narc at
cool dude
trying to help
[Applause]